one of America's 10 most populated
counties will go along with new policies
targeting undocumented immigrants the
decision by miami-dade Florida follows
president Trump's executive order
threatening to take federal funds away
from cities and counties that protect
people from deportation the president
praised Miami Dade tweeting right
decision
strong David big know is in Miami he has
reaction from the county's mayor on that
David good morning Gail good morning
this week big city mayors have been
railing against President Trump's new
executive order on immigration but here
in Miami Dade County the mayor who
actually voted for Hillary Clinton says
his decision is simple it's all about
finances he quite simply doesn't want to
lose federal funding under mounting
pressure from the Trump administration
miami-dade county which is the largest
county in Florida adjusted its detention
policy for illegal immigrants to comply
with orders from Washington in a three
paragraph memo issued Thursday
Republican mayor Carlos Jimenez ordered
jails in miami-dade county to honor all
immigration detainer requests received
from the Department of Homeland Security
we said that we wouldn't hold them
unless they guaranteed that we would get
reimbursed now today my order says don't
worry about the guarantee if the federal
government wants us to hold an
individual immigration you know illegal
immigrants cetera we will hold him for
that for the federal government Mayor
Jimenez says the decision was financial
he told the Miami Herald the county had
declined to hold about 100 inmates last
year which would have cost miami-dade
County about 52 thousand dollars but
that number pales in comparison to the
nearly 355 million in federal funds that
miami-dade is expecting this year I
didn't want to put at risk the millions
of dollars that the federal government
gives to miami-dade County every year
president Trump signed the executive
order Wednesday it threatens to cut
federal funding to cities that don't
comply in detaining people who were here
illegally and have been arrested for
unrelated crimes I'm here to say that
again I I believe in our sanctuary city
status Democratic mayor's in some of the
nation's largest cities are vowing to
fight the Trump administration I want to
say directly to anyone who feels
threatened today
well vulnerable
us safe in Boston I'm willing to lose
every single penny to protect those
people here in miami-dade County the
mayor says look following Trump's
executive order doesn't mean that his
officers are going to go out and become
an immigration force but Charlie he says
what could happen is if you're in the
country illegally and you violate the
law and go to jail for an unrelated
crime you may now be held in the county
jail until federal immigration
authorities pick you up
interesting David thank you